[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will showcase the
ultimate size comparison of the monster
verse we will begin with the small
creatures of Skull Island and the hollow
Earth and gradually go up to the larger
specimens the subtitan species and
finally the super species the Titans we
will include the new Skull Island series
monsters and also estimate the two big
ones scar King and shimu that are going
to appear in gxk the new Empire next
year so essentially this size comparison
will have all the creatures of the most
of us from the movies series books and
the comics so let's get into it
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
so those are all the monster verse
creatures in one video so I hope you
have enjoyed watching this video do hit
the like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel take care
fam
thank you